[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here
and i'm sure you started to notice now a
lot of people customizing
iphone home screens now that it's
possible now that ios 14 is public
and look first of all welcome to the
party we've been we've been customizing
home screens on phones for what 10 years
now
10 plus years but it is kind of fun that
it does feel
a little bit new again now that apple's
finally doing it on their phone
so let's get into that so i've already
done a whole video all about ios 14's
new features everything that's new so if
you want to check that out that's linked
right below the like button
but i noticed a lot of people going back
to that video
and asking home screen questions just as
people figure out that they can
pretty much go ham on their home screen
so for this video just for home screens
i'm going to do
three different levels of home screen
customization
right so level one beginner
someone who'd never really thought much
about this before or you know people who
just got an iphone
level two enthusiast maybe a little more
willing to get your hands dirty a little
more
willing to get complex and then level
three
former android user full tilt
customization
all of the above so let's get into it so
here is a level one setup
to start this one's for you mom and dad
so you've probably gotten used to your
iphone home screen
basically just looking like this just a
bunch of apps a list of them just
rows and rows of apps and folders some
stuff you don't need right
but it's finally time to mess with
widgets now that we've derived with ios
14.
so beautiful glanceable information
that's the point of them and what better
widget to start with than the stock
default apple ones so like i've shown
you just
go into jiggle mode i just go into
jiggle mode and then hit the plus in the
corner and there's some good ones
apple's built in
a popular one right now might be the
photos or notes but i think maybe the
all-time most popular app is just going
to be their weather app
just glanceable weather so you pick the
size of the widget you want
then add it place it where you want boom
that's the first level right
another good one that obviously works
best if you have several apple devices
is the battery one so you can monitor
the watch battery the phone battery
and if you have air pods or really any
other wireless headphones via bluetooth
they'll all show up here which is cool
it's not clickable or anything but it's
just literally showing you
glanceable information the most basic
purpose of a widget
so that's it that's already an
improvement and then of course the other
thing to take advantage of now that
there's the app library over here
is getting rid of the icons or folders
or stuff you don't
need to be on your home screen so again
instead of having pages and pages of
apps and folders of apps you don't need
much on your home screen you've probably
seen this before but yes you can now hit
the dots at the bottom and go ahead and
uncheck a home screen
so it doesn't show up anymore and boom
now you don't have to have
unnecessary crap like you always have
here basically lets you hide apps but
the best part of that that i actually
haven't seen
any android launchers do at least in my
experience yet
is it it saves those hidden pages so you
can bring them back whenever you want so
you can have like a weekend home screen
page
that you only bring back up on the
weekends with i don't know yelp and
strava maybe some games whatever you do
on the weekends
so that's pretty cool also pro tip you
can actually make
your only home screen now have no apps
on it
at all just your dock so if you're under
the minimalism thing
that is available to you but again
that's it there's not many pro tips for
level one
all right so level two this is a little
more adventurous now
so this one you might start to get into
third-party widgets so apple makes some
pretty sweet widgets
sure but now that ios 14 is out
developers are now starting to get into
making their own
best dedicated widgets the most
beautiful the most functional the most
awesome glanceable information
they possibly can in a widget and so
there's a lot of good ones here i'm
going to share some of my favorites so
there's this one called time page that
just makes a straight up
better looking more minimal widget than
apple's weather widget
it's not a weather app it's actually for
something totally different for
productivity but i happen to find
their weather widget pretty sweet so hey
i'll take it
there's also hayweather widget which
offers a few other sizes
and a little more customization the
google widget on ios
is actually pretty nice here so the
bigger one gives you
not just the bar to do quick google
search but you can also quickly start a
voice search
you can start an incognito google text
search
or open google lens to basically google
search for
the image or object that whatever's in
front of you which is pretty sweet when
it works
color widgets and widgery do and widget
smith are also some some really good
widget customization apps and it's
really just the beginning of apps like
this that are made
just to do sweet widgets on the iphone
so i keep saying
sometimes jokingly but that stuff has
been available on android for years that
you're just getting on the iphone
this is a real one where there's like
this entire ecosystem now
of apps that are just for the widget and
you download it and there's really no
functional app behind it other than
widget customization so they each have
their own ui
and their way for customizing widgets to
show information at a glance
whether it's health information from
your apple watch or
news tickers or stocks or weather or the
date and time or battery
or calendar events or really whatever
you want but now you can really go crazy
customizing
exactly what you want in a widget how
you want it to look
what colors and gradients you want it to
use it's it's a whole new horizon and
i'll leave all these that i'm talking
about
linked below and of course if you guys
find good ones and leave them in the
comments
there's a lot of new ones popping up so
i'll i'll update that and leave those
below as well but also something to keep
in mind
a lot of these are like free at their
very basic level of customization
but then as soon as you want to like
change a certain color or add a certain
function in the widget then it becomes
paid
sometimes a subscription sometimes like
a one time four dollar charge or
something
definitely something to keep in mind so
if you're getting into level two you're
really starting to customize stuff
there's gonna be a lot of apps like that
that's the way iphone apps have been for
a while but
just something to note but there you
have level two it gets a little more
personalized
and a little more complex but way more
functional way more worth it so then
last
but not least the level three home
screen
the crazy ones you've seen with
customized icons and
color themes the whole deal so here's
the thing
you can't really actually do custom
icons
yet on the ios home screen i know it
looks like you can we've seen a lot of
cool things that look like that
but these are actually siri shortcuts so
to make one of these
you need the siri shortcuts app so if
you open up shortcuts
you hit that plus you go to add a new
action and you make it an open app
action then you choose the app you want
to open
i'll make this one open the camera app
for example and then you hit the three
dots up here
in the top and hit add to home screen so
now you're making
what appears on the home screen you're
making your icon so you can change the
name of your icon
name it whatever you want and then you
can pick an icon
from your photos or your files pro tip
you can actually leave this name field
blank
for a cleaner look on your home screen
again something i've been doing with
android launchers for years
any chance i can get looks super clean
but yeah once everything's all set
add it and you should find your new
shortcut
on the home screen now here's the
downside because these are still
a workaround these are still siri
shortcuts every time you open one of
these
it has to open the siri shortcuts app
and then use that to shortcut into the
app you want to open and it it does that
every single time and that's kind of
annoying it takes
maybe a quarter of a second maybe half a
second but
it never gets faster over time like
every time you open one of these apps
with a custom icon you'll always have to
wait for that little shortcut to run
and you also don't get any of those
little red badges for apps with
notifications so if you change the
messaging one to a series shortcut
no badge there so it's probably not
ideal to have a whole home screen
full of these but nevertheless that's
what people are doing i've seen a lot of
color-coded home screens on twitter
which are really impressive looking but
we obviously now know
there's a lot going on with shortcuts
happening there but at least now there
are some pretty sweet icon
packs floating around that have a bunch
of icons of the same
style or theme i'll link this one so at
least you don't have to go
googling every single icon you want to
change you can also use a photo you've
taken for an icon if you want to just do
one or two so
that's pretty sweet i'll link this icon
pack and some other cool ones
below for some stylized themed
home screens full of siri shortcuts but
there you have it ios 14
customization on the home screen in
three different levels
possible right now it's not much if
you've seen more than this before you'll
realize but
it's much more than you've ever had in
the last 13 versions of ios so
i'm counting that as a win if you want a
full video of all the other best
features of ios 14
including the double tap on the back to
open google assistant all that other fun
stuff
of course i'll link that video again
below
and if you haven't subscribed already
you probably should there's a lot of
good stuff coming up
including of course the new iphones when
they come up which is like right around
the corner so
definitely stay tuned for that either
way that's been it thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace